[Música]
en repetidas ocasiones el presidente
checo ha estado criticando a la otan
y siempre bueno a favor de lo que dijera
el kremlin y nos ha sorprendido que por
fin él se ha mantenido en silencio
durante mucho tiempo y
después de la invasión de ayer e
incluso miles de más la llamada loco a
putin y ha condenado la invasión con lo
cual se ha conseguido una unanimidad en
este aspecto
no sé si decir que es sorprendente pero
la postura de ese man pues sí que era
muy esperada ver qué decía y lo que ha
dicho bueno habrá que leer es
reconfortante pero bueno
no conocido
con lo cual es algo destacable esta
unanimidad que tenemos en este momento
de apoyo a ucrania
en términos prácticos pues el apoyo
antes de que empezara la invasión
chequeado no cuatro mil balas con
cañones y
ucrania
y ahora pues lo que ahora por ejemplo se
ha aprobado 12 millones de euros de
ayuda humanitaria para los refugiados
y para la gente porque está sufriendo
las consecuencias de los bombardeos y se
espera que haya una
una llegada de inmigrante es muy
importante porque independientemente de
que no haya frontera directa con ucrania
como decías hay muchas conexiones en
varios en varios sentidos y justo es una
de las perspectivas flujos migratorios
que podrían entrar a chequia
en poco tiempo finalmente sobre todo si
están ya entrando a kiev
bueno evidentemente no
ayer se hicieron famosas estas imágenes
de
x colapsada el tráfico sólo en una
dirección evidentemente ellos no iban al
este no iban al oeste muchos de ellos
que tenían a chequia seguro antes estar
a eslovaquia extra polonia que más
grande polonia pero es normal que ya que
muchos tienen familiares en en república
checa que muchos terminen aquí igual que
muchos van a terminar en alemania
francia también en españa también yo
creo que en toda europa se va a sentir
esta ola migratoria porque quien quién
quiere estar allí
[Música]